jean béliveau bonsoir vous êtes ici ce
soir pour nous présenter un merveilleux
cadeau de noël on regarde offrit voulu
nouveau disque de notre chanteur rebelle
florent pagny chante noël
quand tu n'es 100
monsieur
des jouets par milliers
n'oublie pas
oser
parce que ven
jojo
seconde fiscal à tous les
florent pagny chante noël parce que même
à noël vous n'aurez pas ma liberté de
penser
c'est marrant
c'est vieux c'est ce qui est en jeu avec
un précurseur comme moi j'ai subi la
situation j'étais jusqu'au procès j'ai
gagné mon premier procès ils ont fait
appel j'ai gagné l'appel et puis ça
s'est arrêté là je vais inspiré une
chanson formidable
[Musique]
formidable chanson vous est consacré
alors aujourd'hui votre déclaration vous
le faites aux usa donc vous êtes
résident américain n'a une green card
exactement ouais je vis en argentine
ouais et je suis en france voilà et je
paye des impôts en france parce que la
règle française cnet les représentations
c'est sur un territoire français si j'ai
des salaires mais j'en ai passé des
droits d'auteur mais j'ai fait plus de
chansons alors j'ai pas le droit c'est
aux états unis et en argentine je paye
des impôts sur les exploitations et aux
etats unis ces 34% donc ses 34 mais il
ya beaucoup plus de déduction on arrive
presque à 28 je vous conseille d'y aller
mais vous n'êtes plus français alors je
suis citoyen du monde ouais mais je suis
français bienvenue beaucoup de gens
déçus quand vous avez dit je suis plus
français parce qu'ils pensaient que vous
alliez dire je suis plus chanteur moi je
suis français de façon je serai toujours
france est maintenant en effet je
partage ma vie et ma moitié argentine
mes enfants sont français et argentins
et je partage ma vie entre ces deux pays
et donc j'en donnais - finalement des
concerts en france n'ont pas forcément
d'ailleurs attention quand on vote quand
on vote quoi bien quand on vote pour
hollande voilà on a moins de pagny
maintenant voilà à temps pour les gens
les gens regrette alors qu'en fait que
je veuille par exemple l'argent que vous
touchez là c'est en france s'est imposée
en france et un contrôle fiscal la
représentation est en france et je paye
en france d'accord ils vous demandent
beaucoup de conseils les candidats de
voice ans oui en plus fourni qu'à
médiation beaucoup
bon alors on passe aux choses c'est à la
mer si vous êtes ce soir ici pour un
nouvel album jamais vieillir avec toi
qui sert trouvait être en tête des
ventes dès sa sortie et qui est déjà
double platine
[Applaudissements]
alors le disque on peut l'acheter en
liquide
mais nathan on le dit ce qu'il fait le
piquet même goûté on peut le télécharger
bien sûr également voilà voilà comme ça
parce que lui après ça lui fait trop
mais non mais non avec les poches que
j'ai moi c'est
alors l'album cartonne vraiment c'est là
qu'on voit que le vrai gagnant de voice
est jury finalement non
c'est pas un jury et des coachs ont fait
un jeu à vous faites cela très bien être
le sage tout le mec et même moi je m'y
attendais pas être sage dit mme wade est
bon je me suis quand même un truc un
truc tous les samedis soir sur tf1 t'as
pas intérêt à parler de trop non plus
gauck l'asie mais elle a un peu en
veilleuse parce que moi je suis plutôt
bavard ouais c'est un truc comme qu'il
faut dire vous avez un truc que les
autres n'ont pas vous sérieusement une
voix incroyable la nature a été très
gentille avec moi elle m'a fait un don
plusieurs même pas ce qu'il y'a pas que
la voix est aussi l'oreille police deux
foyers oui parce que pour arriver à
chanter juste faut bien entendre et
c'est vrai que j'ai ce truc qui depuis
l'âge de 2 10 ans max panier même
chantier quand j'étais petit mexico le
chantier du
label de qualité que ça chantait un peu
mais je vous vois venir mais dès que ça
chante maintenant que je chantais à
merci alors j'en peux plus
c calogero je suis là devant tout
l'album composé et réalisé par calogero
1 florence pour les parents lionel
florence à la bastide marc lavoine
lavoine aussi christophe cirilo et
emmanuelle cosso mais
[Applaudissements]
cet album évidemment virique toi c'est
une déclaration d'amour azucena fait
vingt ans que vous êtes ensemble et vous
dites qu'on vous en parle ça va durer
vous dit j'ai l'impression d'avoir
rencontré le mois dernier on a de la
chance tous les deux de cette retrouver
et d'être d'être vraiment
complémentaires et de voir vingt ans
passés comme si c'était pas pareil
alors
avec asus yona
les deux enfants inca et à l est un cas
va avoir 18 ans il ya les prochaines
pouvoir faire un procès pour le prénom
je pense il en est très contente les
gens se moquent pas de lui non non non
t'inquiète pas est grand et beau comme
il est personne ce bocal
alors on va rester dans la musique à
faire un blind test mais tout le monde
peut jouer
aussi tu veux on peut jouer alors le
thème du blind test je ne serais pas
surpris chez les chanteurs qui ont eu
des problèmes avec le fisc
attention dj
pour la laddh
[Musique]
polnareff ben voilà
allez on
il va bien ouais ouais
attention didier ont peu à voir avec le
fils richard bravo
partout là
c'était bien cette fois ce n'est pas sur
l'impro et attention
donnée
m
il a été obligé de payer 100 millions au
fisc à un johnny c'est chaud quand même
bref vous c'est moi ouais ouais ouais
bah je gagne moi ouais
attention didier
[Musique]
sympa de savoir
il avait d'ailleurs beaucoup d'humour à
l'époque dans le carnaval il sortait de
prison était venu faire l'émission avec
la vie de
deux prisonniers avec le boulet
il était en prison oui absolument à
pontoise et il a fallu que ses proches
rassemble 150 2000 euros pour le faire
sortir et la jetta des potes
difficilement tu restes attention didier
non mais l'on laisse gagner les filles
absolument à ouaga on continue didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore
j'en ai dit que je t'aime allez hop dj
attention dj
caution
ancien nous allons bien
après tout aucune femme chanteuse qui
dans sa façon par faire
didier
alaime enrico
macias
et
dans ses jambes
[Musique]
il ya une enquête sur sa société le
potage comment ça s'est passé montage
financier de sanofi il n'a pas été
condamné attention didier
la liberté de penser
c'est vrai pour l'anecdote c'est vrai
pour l'anecdote c'est ma plus grosse
chansons alors moi je suis heureusement
on a pu heureusement du seigneur ouais
ouais c'est la plus grosse vente de
singles et c'est vrai que je dois être
le seul de ce sujet là à s'en sortir a
même gagné de la
correction de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus